I mean best case scenario November MSG
you know me and Patty on that main card
he needs uh December Vegas that doesn't
sound too bad either would you jump
across the pond and fight him in his own
backyard too a hundred percent man I
would love to go to London and fight him
there it would be so cool to go there
never been but he also replied on uh
Twitter was like yeah let's do it he's
like he's gonna be the easiest route to
get into the top 15. I was like yes I
don't know about that Patty I don't
blame him man I even you look at the top
15 of the lightweight Division I mean
anyone anybody could beat anybody on any
given day I think me and him will just
have such an exciting fight